Dieter Nuhr.
Was haben alle mit ihm,
er ist doch ... nur Dieter.
(Tusch)
Ich hab das ungute Gefühl,
was Dummes zu machen,
nämlich ein differenziertes Video
über Dieter Nuhr.
Denn der Mann ist so polarisierend,
da ... ey!
Warum disliked ihr schon?
Es hat nicht mal angefangen.
Come on! Willkommen zur "maiLab"
Drama-Analyse.
falls ihr das Drama um Nuhr und
die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft
nicht mitbekommen habt,
kurzes Recap.
Alle anderen können überspringen.
Die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft,
die DFG,
möchte mit ihrer aktuellen Kampagne
Gemeinsam # für das Wissen:
Die DFG sammelt Statements,
in denen sich Menschen
für das Wissen aussprechen,
darunter auch Dieter Nuhr.
Letzte Woche Donnerstag
wurde Nuhrs Statement gepostet,
and people were not having it.
(Die Posts werden schnell
vorgelesen.)
Am nächsten Morgen meldete sich
die DFG:
And people were not having it.
Wohlgemerkt gab es sowohl gegen Nuhr
als auch gegen die DFG
viele nicht so sachliche
Beschimpfungen und Beleidigungen,
die ich hier nicht wiederholen
oder einblenden werde,
aber ihr könnt euch denken,
dass in dem Storm Shit war.
Wir bleiben wie immer
sachlich entspannt,
deswegen holt ein 'n Tee, meinetwegen
Eistee für den Extrachill,
macht es euch gemütlich, los geht's.
(Rhythmische Musik)
So, Freunde der Sonne.
Wir analysieren das Drama
unter fünf Gesichtspunkten,
es wird quasi
ein Drama in fünf Akten.
Wir hören mal, was Nuhr
in seinem Statement im O-Ton sagte.
(Nuhr:) Wissen bedeutet nicht, dass
man sich zu 100 Prozent sicher ist,
sondern, dass man
über genügend Fakten verfügt,
um begründete Meinungen zu haben.
Da viele beleidigt sind, wenn
Wissenschaftler Meinungen ändern.
Das ist normal.
Wissenschaft ist grade,
dass sich die Meinung ändert,
wenn sich Fakten ändern.
Wissenschaft ist nämlich
keine Heilslehre, keine Religion,
die totale Wahrheiten verkündet.
Und wer ständig ruft:
"Folgt der Wissenschaft!",
der hat das wohl nicht begriffen.
(Dieter Nuhrs Stimme liest
den eingeblendeten Post vor.)
Moment mal!
Wo hab ich das schon mal gehört?
Wissenschaft ist nicht
DIE Wahrheit.
Aber sie ist die beste Näherung,
die uns zur Verfügung steht.
Wissenschaft bedeutet, fortlaufend
neue Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen.
Ja, nur Vollidioten legen sich
auf eine Meinung fest,
wenn es ständig
neue Erkenntnisse gibt!
"Neue Experimente
bringen neue Erkenntnisse,
die dazu führen, das, was man
bis dahin als "wahr" annahm,
infrage stellen muss."
Ist ... ist Dieter Nuhr
ein Freund der Sonne?
Nein. Also, wer weiß?
Vielleicht ist er es.
Ich will damit nur sagen,
kein Zufall,
dass wir uns überschneiden.
Das ist ganz normal.
Da sein Statement sehr konform ist
mit dem,
was viele WissenschafterInnen sagen.
Weil es einfach stimmt.
Warum dann die Kritik?
Die Kritik an Nuhrs Statement
lässt sich kurz
hierin zusammenfassen:
Wer unwissenschaftlichen Blödsinn
erzählt,
soll nicht für die DFG und
Wissen stehen, so das Argument.
Einige halten auch dagegen,
und zwar nicht nur Fans -
nicht Nuhr Fans.
(Tusch)
Sorry. Die sagen:
Man muss seine Comedy nicht mögen,
aber wo er recht hat ...
Wie unwissenschaftlich Nuhr
tatsächlich ist,
das schauen wir uns in Teil drei
und vier an,
klären wir erst eine Grundsatzfrage.
Ist der Backlash gegen Nuhr
nicht ein ad hominen-Argument?
Also: Ein Angriff gegen eine Person,
keine Argumentation in der Sache.
Das ist wie Greta anzugreifen,
ohne Klimaforschung zu machen.
Es gibt Situationen,
wo das Trennen zwischen Argument
und Person
nicht möglich oder sinnvoll ist.
Etwa bei solchen Statements.
Natürlich geht es da um die Sache,
das Wissen.
Aber der Witz
bei solchen Statements ist,
dass prominente Personen
mit ihrer Person, mit ihrem Gesicht
für diese Sache stehen.
Solange man Dieter Nuhr
nicht als Person angreift,
sondern seine Aussagen,
also Inhalte, kritisiert,
ist es okay,
sich daran zu stören,
wenn die inkonsistent sind.
Etwa, wenn er
in seinen Bühnenprogrammen
sich gegen Wissenschaft ausspricht
und dann in diesem Statement dafür.
Aber macht er das?
"Ich hab noch nie wissenschafts-
feindlich argumentiert", sagt er.
Na, wissenschaftsfeindlich ist
für mich zumindest
ein sehr starkes Wort,
das würde ich jetzt für harte
Wissenschaftsverweigerer verwenden.
Ha, Mist. Schwappt mir der Tee über
bei Wissenschaftsverweigerern.
Aber wie steht Nuhr zur Wissenschaft?
Regelmäßig behandelt er
wissenschaftliche Themen,
teilt dabei Kritik aus,
was nicht verkehrt ist,
aber ist die Kritik angemessen
für wen, der sich:
Großer Freund der Wissenschaft.
- ... nennt.
Ich hab mir
seine aktuellen Auftritte angeschaut
und drei wiederkehrende Kritikpunkte
festgestellt.
Dann rufen alle: "Ja, wir sterben!"
Jahrelang wurde über
nichts anderes geredet,
als über Feinstaub und Stickoxide.
Bis man es nicht mehr hören konnte.
Nun interessiert sich
keine Sau mehr dafür.
Ne, das ist doch irre,
wie wir Hysterien entwickeln.
Ein Jahr lang war hier
eine Hysterie.
Kein Wissenschaftler behauptet,
die Erde werde unbewohnbar.
Niemand. Die Wissenschaft sagt,
es wird wärmer,
und das will ich nicht
verharmlosen,
das ist alles andere als gut,
das ist ein großes Problem.
Aber durchdrehen hilft nicht.
Hier könnte man Klimahysterie
diagnostizieren,
aber das geht nicht mehr.
Klimahysterie ist das Unwort
des Jahres.
Ich will das Problem nicht
kleinreden, ich glaube nur,
Hysterie hilft nicht.
Damit schlägt er ja den Gegenton an
zum Beispiel zu einer Greta Thunberg,
die sagt:
I don't want you to be hopeful.
I want you to panic.
I want you to act
as if the house was on fire.
Because it is.
Ist er deswegen
ein Klimawandel-Leugner?
Natürlich nicht.
Richtet er Schaden an,
indem er ernstzunehmende Krisen
verharmlost?
Begünstigt er, dass Wissenschaft-
ler nicht gehört werden?
Natürlich ist es besser,
Krisen mit kühlem Kopf anzugehen.
Aber da bei Kommunikation
nicht das zählt, was man sagt,
sondern nur das,
was beim anderen ankommt,
finde ich es beim Klimawandel
nicht so verkehrt,
wenn Greta sagt:
- "I want you to panic."
Weil wir da meiner Meinung nach
weit davon entfernt sind,
Panik zu schieben.
Ich finde, wir sind viel zu träge,
das liegt daran,
dass man die Klimawandelfolgen
nicht so konkret sieht,
wie etwa die sekündlich verfolgbaren
Corona Infektions- und Todeszahlen.
Bei unserem "Corona geht erst los"-
Video, überlegten wir lange,
wie wir diese ernüchternde Message
angemessen rüberbringen.
Weil wir Angst hatten,
Angst auszulösen.
Ist natürlich tricky.
Ich will keine Hysterie oder Panik,
wo irrationale Entscheidungen
getroffen werden,
aber ich will auch nicht ...
so was.
(stammelnd:) What the fuck?
Auf der
Wissenschaft-ernst-nehmen-Skala,
die sich erstreckt
von irrationaler Panik
bis hin zu Corona-Demos in Berlin,
liegt Dieter Nuhr in einem Bereich,
in dem man verschiedene persönliche
Meinungen und Wahrnehmungen
akzeptieren sollte,
ohne dass man zustimmen muss.
Wenn Nuhr findet,
wir sind zu hysterisch,
ich find, sind wir nicht,
dann ist das Ansichtssache,
die man schwer faktisch klären kann.
Denn wie sagte diese Philosophin,
die heute kaum jemand kennt?
Greta hieß sie, glaub ich, sie sagte:
"Folgt der Wissenschaft!"
Aber das ist bei Corona
nicht so einfach.
Ja, welcher denn?
Der von Herrn Drosten,
Herrn Streeck oder Herrn Kekulé?
Glad you asked, dazu auch ein Video.
Da sieht man, wie bescheuert
der Satz schon immer war.
Als gäbe es
EINE wissenschaftliche Wahrheit.
Und wegen solcher Aussagen haben
einige Nuhrs DFG-Statement
auch inhaltlich kritisiert,
genau diese Stelle hier:
Wissenschaft ist nämlich
keine Heilslehre, keine Religion,
die totale Wahrheiten verkündet.
Wer ständig ruft:
"Folgt der Wissenschaft!",
der hat das wohl nicht begriffen.
Der Vergleich
zwischen Wissenschaft und Religion
wird auch politisch gern eingesetzt,
um Wissenschaft Evidenzbasis
abzusprechen.
Als sei es nur Glaubenssache.
"Klimareligion" ist etwa
ein beliebter Kampfbegriff
lupenreiner
Wissenschaftsverweigerern.
Nur, da es nicht
DIE Wahrheit gibt,
kann man
"Folgt der Wissenschaft!", rufen.
Der Slogan: "Beruft euch
auf wissenschaftliche Evidenz
und ändert eure Meinung,
mit neuen Erkenntnissen!",
ist halt etwas sperrig.
Ich sah, dass sich Nuhr
über skurrile Studien lustig macht
bzw. über skurrile Schlagzeilen
über Studien.
Rauchen galt wissenschaftlich gesehen
immer als gesundheitsgefährdend,
jetzt ist es plötzlich gesund.
Haben Sie das gehört?
Ja, also, jetzt nicht gesund,
aber es hilft gegen Corona.
99 Prozent der Corona-Toten sind
Nichtraucher.
Wär was für unser "Schlagzeilen
wissenschaftlich geprüft."
Ein lustiges Bild.
Alle rauchen,
um dem Virus zu entkommen.
Wenn im Kindergarten alle so
mit Kippe im Sandkasten sitzen.
Na, stell ich mir lustig vor.
"Folgt der Wissenschaft!"
Wer behauptet denn
"Folgt der Wissenschaft!" hieße,
folge jeder x-beliebigen Studie?
Soll man nicht machen.
Da hat er recht.
Bringt mich
zu meinem zweiten Punkt:
es gibt zwar nicht DIE Wahrheit,
aber es gibt in vielen Bereichen
wissenschaftlichen Konsens.
Und dem zu folgen,
ist nicht religiös,
das ist einfach nur vernünftig.
Eine Studie über Corona und Rauchen
ist kein wissenschaftlicher Konsens,
dass der Klimawandel menschgemacht
ist, ist es.
Der wissenschaftliche Konsens
in der Klimaforschung,
die seit Jahrzehnten betrieben wird,
ist größer,
als bei einem neuen Virus,
das seit Monaten die Welt verdreht.
So hab ich ihn mal paraphrasiert,
aber am besten ist da der O-Ton.
Aber den Tod an sich
können wir nicht verhindern.
Bei Corona gilt,
und da ist die Statistik eindeutig,
die meisten Coronaopfer:
sehr alt, vorerkrankt.
Corona ist meist nicht die Ursache
des Todes,
sondern nur der Beschleuniger.
Und vieles beschleunigt den Tod.
Jedes Bier lässt uns früher sterben.
Das nehmen wir hin, da der Tod
nüchtern nicht zu ertragen ist.
350.000 Menschen sterben bei uns
jährlich an Herzklabastern.
Das könnten wir verhindern.
Eine Sportpflicht,
zwei Stunden am Tag oder drei,
Alkoholverbot, Sitzverbot,
tägliche Ernährungsprüfung
durch einen Gesundheitsblockwart,
alle 20 Minuten 'ne SMS:
"Beweg dich, faule Sau!"
Wir hätten 100.000 Tote weniger.
Das kann man wollen.
Muss man aber nicht.
Ganz ähnliche Argumente brachte
er im Januar über Feinstaubdebatte.
Erst mal, dass er hier
offenbar andeutet,
dass Corona nicht so schlimm ist,
da Menschen betroffen sind,
die eh bald sterben ...
Ganz großes Uff.
- Erstens stimmt das nicht.
Jemand mit 'ner Herz-Kreislauf-
Erkrankung, mit Diabetes,
mit Lungenerkranung,
geschwächtem Immunsystem
stirbt doch nicht eh bald.
Und zweitens und eigentlich erstens:
Ethik?
Anyone? Nein?
Was staatliche Schutzmaßnahmen
betrifft, hat er recht.
Ein Staat kann Bürger
in gewissem Rahmen schützen,
etwa mit Gurtpflicht.
Aber das meiste ist mit gutem Grund
Entscheidungsfreiheit.
Wo zieht man die Linie?
Es ist meine Sache,
wie viel ich trinke,
sitze und Sport ich mache,
aber für mich wird die Sache
anders,
sobald mein Verhalten andere
gefährdet.
Ich finde nicht, dass man
Zigaretten verbieten sollte.
Aber ich finde es gut,
wenn in Restaurants
Rauchverbot herrscht,
da niemand gegen seinen Willen
Schadstoffe einatmen soll.
Daher finde ich auch
Corona-Schutzmaßnahmen richtig.
Aber das sind alles keine
wissenschaftlichen Fragen mehr.
Wissenschaft kann nur feststellen,
wie gefährlich was ist.
Was wir daraus machen,
sind sozialpolitische,
ethische Fragen.
Und ich weiß, Nuhr eckt bei vielen an
und viele sind jetzt enttäuscht,
dass ich nicht auf
weitere Aussagen eingehe,
aber Leute,
wir haben gar nicht so viel Zeit,
Nuhrs ganzes Bühnenprogramm
zu analysieren,
der Mann steht seit 30 Jahren
auf der Bühne.
Vor allem wollte ich einen
wissenschaftlichen Fokus legen.
Denn wir erinnern:
es geht hier um das DFG-Drama,
und der Vorwurf dort
war "Unwissenschaftlichkeit".
Also, um Teil drei abzuschließen:
Ist Dieter Nuhr ein ...
- großer Freund der Wissenschaft?
(Sie summt und stöhnt.)
Das ist Ansichtssache.
Aber würde ich Nuhr als
wissenschaftsfeindlich bezeichnen?
Nein. Aber das ist auch nur
meine Meinung.
Lassen wir Meinungen sein
und kommen zum nächsten Punkt:
Wie wissenschaftlich korrekt
ist Dieter Nuhr?
Ich hab mir nicht
30 Bühnenjahre von Nuhr angesehen,
aber unter den neueren Sachen sind
mir ein paar Fehler aufgefallen:
drei Beispiele.
Fangen wir an mit der
Diesel-Stickoxid-Feinstaubdebatte.
(Lachen)
Nee.
Das ist nicht so.
Besagter empfohlener Stickoxidgrenz-
wert von 40 Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter
ist der Grenzwert für das Mittel
von einem Jahr.
Der empfohlene Grenzwert
für eine Stunde
liegt bei Innenräumen aber
bei 200 Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter.
Das heißt, wenn eine Kerze
120 Mikrogramm Stickoxid produziert,
überschreitet das nicht den Grenzwert
und erst recht nicht,
wenn man alles durch
die Kubikmeter Raum teilt,
denn eine Konzentration
ist Menge pro Volumen.
Zweites Beispiel:
- Hilft die Maske?
Gegen Ansteckung hilft sie nix,
weil die Viren viel zu klein sind.
Die gehen da durch
wie durch ein offenes Scheunentor.
Die Datenlage zu Masken ist
erstaunlich schlecht.
Es gibt Studien, aber die
haben alle methodische Probleme,
etwa dass man den Effekt der Masken
nicht trennen kann
vom Effekt anderer Schutzmaßnahmen.
Aber!
Auch, wenn Viren durch die Poren
so einer Maske passen,
ist es nicht unplausibel,
dass wir wenigstens einen Teil
zurückhalten.
Also, wenn ich jetzt huste
oder spucke beim Reden,
dann katapultiere ich meine
Virenspucke im Zweifelsfall
ins Gesicht meines Gegenübers,
und natürlich hält das
so 'ne Maske ab.
Es wäre gefährlich zu denken, dass
Masken vor Ansteckungen schützen.
Sie sind kein Ersatz für
Sicherheitsabstand.
Aber es ist auch gefährlich zu sagen:
Die helfen nix.
Denn überall da,
wo man keinen Abstand halten kann,
kann die Maske etwas verhindern.
Drittes Beispiel:
- Vom ersten Moment an wusste man
beim Robert Koch-Institut auf
die Stelle hinter dem Komma genau,
wie hoch die Sterblichkeit
bei Covid-19 ist.
Obwohl niemand bis heute weiß,
wie viele überhaupt infiziert sind.
Weil das nur repräsentative Tests
sagen können.
Weshalb auch niemand ausrechnen kann,
wie viel Prozent der Infizierten
ableben.
Da fehlt schlicht und einfach
die wichtigste Variable.
Und Kenntnis vorzutäuschen,
ist nicht wissenschaftlich
und nicht seriös,
sondern sogar ärgerlich,
weil die Wissenschaft ist
die einzige wirkliche Wissensquelle,
die wir haben.
Und da finde ich es schön, wenn
Institutionen wie das RKI etwa
nicht den Ruf der Wissenschaft
als Ganzes runterziehen würden,
indem sie Wissen vortäuschen,
wo keins ist.
Er hat recht, dass es bei Corona
eine Dunkelziffer gibt
und dass wir deswegen
die Infektionssterblichkeit,
also Todesfälle geteilt durch
alle Infektionsfälle,
nur schätzen können.
Was das RKI oder auch die
Johns Hopkins University berichten,
ist Fallsterblichkeit,
die Anzahl der Todesfälle
unter den gemeldeten Fällen.
Aber es wurde auch nie was anderes
behauptet,
im Gegenteil.
Am Anfang wurde drauf hingewiesen,
dass etwa die Fallzahlen
mit mehr Tests steigen werden,
dass dafür die Sterblichkeit
sinkt usw.
Das RKI hat nie vorgegeben
oder vorgetäuscht,
die reale Infektionssterblichkeit
zu wissen und vermitteln.
Also, das stimmt schlichtweg nicht.
Das hat er wohl falsch verstanden.
Okay.
Nuhrs Comedy ist oft
nicht wissenschaftlich korrekt.
Schlimm?
Schaden wird's ihm kaum.
Wir messen Satire, Comedy nicht
an wissenschaftlicher Korrektheit.
Ich fände das toll,
stellt euch vor,
jeder, der/die sich
in der Öffentlichkeit äußert,
müsste fact checken
und recherchieren.
Stellt euch vor, alle würden
ihre Kommentare erst fact checken,
bevor sie sie irgendwo hinkotzen.
Das wär 'ne entspanntere Welt.
Aber bestimmt auch
eine weniger witzige Welt.
Also, Witze sind nun mal pointiert
und zugespitzt,
sie übertreiben und verkürzen.
Wendet man das
auf Wissenschaftliches an,
ist das eine Garantie für
wissenschaftliche Inkorrektheit.
Wobei ich nicht sagen will,
dass man Wissenschaft nicht humorvoll
vermitteln kann.
Ich meine, ich bin ja
das beste Beispiel dafür.
Er ist doch ...
(verzerrt:) nur Dieter.
Ich will damit nur sagen ...
Ich will damit Nuhr sagen ...
(Tusch)
Ich lass es, sorry.
Wir müssen Comedy nicht an wissen-
schaftlicher Korrektheit messen,
aber wir müssen so quellen-
und medienkompetent sein,
Satire über wissenschaftliche Inhalte
nicht als wissenschaftliche
Quelle zu sehen,
sondern eben nur als Unterhaltung.
So. Aber!
Sollte ein nicht immer
wissenschaftlich korrekter Satiriker
ein Statement für das Wissen
für die DFG abgeben?
Hätte die DFG Nuhr
erst gar nicht fragen sollen?
Aus ihrer Sicht sicherlich ja,
da hätten sie sich viel erspart.
Ist es okay, dass die DFG
einen schon veröffentlichten Beitrag
wieder löscht?
Was eine andere Gewichtung hat,
als jemanden nicht zu fragen.
Sagen wir, das Kampagnenteam
die DFG wusste nichts
von den Kontroversen rund um Nuhr,
haben das durch den Backlash erfahren
und haben dann
Aussagen von ihm reviewed
und dann befunden ...
ach, nee ...
Doch nicht.
Das passt nicht zu unserer Haltung,
das finden wir nicht konsistent,
hätten wir das gewusst,
hätten wir nicht gefragt: Löschen.
Okay. Aber ...
dann muss man das auch begründen.
Stattdessen war
die einzige Begründung:
(Sie liest den ersten Teil vor.)
Nichts, ob sie der Kritik
inhaltlich zustimmen.
Heißt das,
der Beitrag wurde gelöscht,
einfach nur, weil er unbeliebt war?
Aber schaut euch das an.
Exakt jetzt,
wo ich dieses Video aufnehme,
veröffentlicht die DFG
ein ausführliches Statement,
wo sie quasi sagen:
Sorry, aber wir waren
einfach nur überfordert.
Und ja, ich denke, genauso war's.
Also an alle, die direkt "Zensur!"
geschrien haben. Beruhigt euch mal.
Und die DFG bezieht ziemlich klar
Stellung,
dass sie nicht Stellung beziehen.
Die Kritik zum Religionsvergleich
haben sie verstanden,
aber möchten ausdrücklich nicht
darüber werten.
Nach dieser Begründung ist
die logische Folge,
dass sie den Beitrag wieder online
nehmen, was Sie Nuhr auch anbieten,
und zwar "im Lichte
der aktuellen Debatte kommentiert".
Das ist natürlich
alles sehr ...
unglücklich.
Dieter Nuhr hat das Angebot der DFG
abgelehnt,
was wenig überrascht.
Auch, wenn ich zugegebenermaßen
nicht auf die Idee gekommen wäre,
Dieter Nuhr aktiv anzufragen,
jeder und jede sollte sich
in der Öffentlichkeit
zur Wissenschaft bekennen dürfen.
Ich denk nicht, dass man dafür
wissenschaftlich perfekt sein muss.
Wenn etwa die Grünen
die Partei der Wissenschaft
sein wollen,
wegen Klimapolitik und so - super.
Natürlich weiß ich, dass die Grünen
bei Themen wie Homöopathie
oder grüner Gentechnik
nicht dieselbe Wissenschaftlichkeit
zur Schau stellen.
Verlange ich deswegen,
dass die Grünen
ihre Verschreibung der Wissenschaft
zurückziehen sollen?
Klar, kann man.
Aber ich ziehe es vor,
die Grünen auf ihre Wissenschafts-
liebe festzunageln,
wie Lars es etwa
aus unserem "maiLab"-Team gerne tut.
Bei dieser Gelegenheit:
folg Lars auf Twitter.
Er ist da viel informativer
und lustiger als ich.
Und wer sagt denn,
dass Nuhr nicht mal
seine Meinung ändern kann,
wenn man ihn nicht
mit Beschimpfungen,
sondern Fakten konfrontiert,
und an sein Statement erinnert.
Zum Beispiel haben sich im März viele
furchtbar über diesen Tweet von Nuhr
aufgeregt.
Immerhin räumte er öffentlich
auch ein:
Viele haben die Krankheit
unterschätzt, ich im Übrigen auch.
Um es deutlich zu sagen.
Und deswegen finde ich es gut,
wenn sich Dieter Nuhr öffentlich
zur Wissenschaft bekennt.
Denn damit lädt er uns ja ein,
seine Arbeit nicht nur anhand
von Unterhaltung,
sondern auch wissenschaftlicher
Korrektheit zu bewerten,
und das ist doch
eigentlich nur gut, oder?
Ich hoffe, das Drama hat der DFG
und der wirklich schönen Kampagne
wenigstens ein bisschen
Aufmerksamkeit gebracht,
denn: there is no such thing
as bad PR? Vielleicht.
In der Endcard verlinke ich
unser Wissenschaftler-Ehrenvideo
und ein Video von Ranga Yogeshwar.
Ranga ist ja, seit ich denken kann,
eine der stärksten Stimmen
für die Wissenschaft,
und er hat bei diesem Videostatement
auch mitgemacht
bei "Für das Wissen".
Und nachdem er mir im TV seine
Nachfolge bei "Quarks" überließ,
hat er jetzt mit YouTube angefangen,
was natürlich meganice ist,
ganz heiße Kanalempfehlung von mir.
Unbedingt abonnieren.
Und hinterlasst Ranga gerne
viele liebe Kekse von mir.
Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen,
bis dahin: bleibt sicher!